>> NOW, BOYCOTT THE BEIJING
GAMES, THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT ANGLE.
>> THE FOLLOWING ARE
INDISPUTABLE FACTS.
CHINA IS A BRUTAL DICTATORSHIP.
OF REPRESSIVE REGIME.
CHINA DOES NOT RECOGNIZE
INDIVIDUAL FREEDOMS, FREEDOM TO
WORSHIP, SPEAK FREELY,
PETITIONED PETITION THE
GOVERNMENT.
FACT, CHINA HAS IMPRISONED AND
TORTURED POLITICAL DISSIDENTS
FOR WHICH THEY HAVE MERCK
CURRENTLY MORE THAN MILLION
MUSLIMS IN REEDUCATION CAMPS.
SO HOW DOES CHINA KEEP ITS
CITIZENS IN LINE?
1.3 BILLION?
THROUGH INTIMIDATION AND FEAR,
AND A VAST SURVEILLANCE NETWORK.
ACCORDING TO THE BBC, BY 2018,
THERE WERE ALREADY ABOUT
200 MILLION SURVEILLANCE CAMERAS
IN CHINA.
BY 2021, THIS NUMBER IS EXPECTED
TO REACH 560 MILLION.
ROUGHLY ONE FOR EVERY TWO-POINT
FOR CITIZENS.
NOW, PEACEFUL PROTESTERS IN HONG
KONG TRIED THEIR BEST TO AVOID
BEING CAUGHT ON SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS THEY BOW DOWN AND KINDA
WALKED BELOW THEM, BUT MASK
WEARING WAS PROBABLY A BIGGER
HELP THAN THEIR CAMERA DODGING.
>> IN CHINA’S AGGRESSIVE
AMBITIONS AREN’T LIMITED TO
THEIR OWN BORDERS OR TO ASIA.
THEY WANT THE ENTIRE WORLD WITH
AMERICA BEING THE CROWN JEWEL.
DOMINATING AMERICA MEANS
DEFEATING US ECONOMICALLY AND TO
ADVANCE THAT GOAL, THEY ARE
INFILTRATING AMERICAN INSTITUTE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
INSTITUTION INSTITUTIONS.
ONE ESTIMATE PUTS THE NUMBER OF
CHINESE STUDENT STUDYING IN THE
UNITED STATES AT A STAGGERING
350,000.
OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
HAVE BECOME INFESTED WITH CCP
AGENTS.
ONE RECENT EXAMPLE IS THE
UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS PROFESSOR
WHO THE FEDS ACCUSED OF STEALING
PROPRIETARY TECHNOLOGY FROM U.S.
TECH STARTED UP AND HANDING IT
OVER TO THE CCP CONTROLLED.
DHS WARNED THAT CHINESE MADE
DRONES WE’RE PROVIDING U.S.
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT DATA TO THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
WHAT DOES THE CCP WANT THAT DATA
FOR?
WHAT DID THEY PLAN TO DO WITH IT
?
THE FIRST PART, THE EU, DRAFTER
CASH IS DESPERATE FOR FUNDS TO
SUPPORT ITS STRUGGLING ECONOMY.
IT DOESN’T SEEM TO CARE THAT
MUCH ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS IN CHINA
.
>> THEY CHINESE PRESIDENT SPOKE
YESTERDAY AND HE AND I AGREE ON
THAT.
WE SEE MULTILATERALISM.
>> WE NEED TO FIND BETWEEN
STATES COMMIT TO GO BACK TO IN
MULTILATERALISM.
>> AMERICA IS BACK, DIPLOMACY IS
BACK, AT THE CENTER OF OUR
FOREIGN POLICY.
>> AMERICA IS BACK, READY TO
LEAD THE WORLD.
>> TRANSLATION, APPEASEMENT,
IT’S UPON US.
IT’S FUNNY THOUGH, THEY NEVER
SEEM TO HESITATE WHEN IT’S TIME
TO CRITICIZE US, THE VOTERS PRAY
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM CRITICIZING
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN AMERICA
FIRST, BUT CHINA, THEY BACK AWAY
.
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO LEAD THE
WORLD IF THEY HAVE TO GO HAVE IN
HAND TO AN EVIL REGIME LIKE
CHINA?
THAT’S NOT LEADING, THAT’S
GIVING IN.
JOB BIDEN CLAIMS THAT AMERICA’S
BACK AND HE WANTS TO BE A WORLD
LEADER, IF THAT’S REALLY TRUE,
HE SHOULD START BY ANNOUNCING A
BOYCOTT OF THE 2022 WINTER GAMES
IN BEIJING, AND THEN CONVINCE
OUR ALLIES AND ELSEWHERE TO JOIN
THE BOYCOTT.
WHEN THE OLYMPIC COMMITTEE LET
HITLER HOST THE 1936 GAMES IN
BERLIN, IT WAS A DARK STAIN ON
THE GAMES THAT LASTED FOR
DECADES.
IT WAS JUST BIG PROPAGANDA, A
COUP FOR THE REGIME, AND IT WILL
BE THE SAME FOR THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST.
IMAGINE THE PRESIDENT WALKING
INTO THAT STADIUM FOR THE FIRST
TIME LORDING OVER THE CROWD,
PACKED IN TIGHT TO SHOW THAT THE
DECADENT WEST BOY, YOU GUYS
HAVEN’T OVERCOME COVID, BUT WE
HAVE WITH HIS AIR OF SUPERIORITY
.
IF WE WERE THERE, IF THE UNITED
STATES IS THERE, THE CCP WILL
JUST ARGUE THAT OUR COMPLAINTS
ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS DON’T MEAN
ANYTHING, WE JUST SAY THAT WE
MOUTH THE WORDS, WE’RE JUST TOO
WEAK TO RESIST CHINA.
THAT WE WILL ALWAYS DO WHAT WE
ARE TOLD.
AND MANY OBSERVERS AROUND THE
WORLD I’M AFRAID WILL AGREE.
NOW IN THE PAST, WE’VE HAD
PRESIDENTS WHO WE’RE BRAVE
ENOUGH TO TAKE ON THE REGIME,
JIMMY CARTER COULD STAND UP TO
THE USSR IN 1980, BIDEN CAN
STAND UP TO THE CCP TODAY.
BUT, I’M NOT HOLDING MY BREATH.
FOR MOST OF HIS CAREER, OLD JOE
HAS DEFENDED CHINA FROM HIS
CRITICS.
AND HE IS STILL DOING SO.
>> HAD THE IDEA THAT I’M NOT
GOING TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST WHAT
HE’S DOING IN HONG KONG, WHAT HE
IS DOING IN THE WESTERN
MOUNTAINS OF CHINA, AND TAIWAN
BY MAKING IT FORCEFUL, HE GETS
IT.
CULTURALLY, WE ARE DIFFERENT
NORMS IN EACH COUNTRY, AND THE
LEADERS ARE EXPECTED TO FOLLOW.
>> IT’S JUST DIFFERENT CULTURAL
NORMS.
DO YOU SEE WHAT HE DID THERE?
OF COURSE ESTABLISHMENT FIGURES
SUCH AS MITT ROMNEY, THEY ARE
PUSHING BACK ON THE IDEA OF A
BOYCOTT CLAIMING IT WOULD PUNISH
OUR ATHLETES.
TO BE BLUNT, THAT IS JUST
PATHETIC.
THE ANGLE EMPATHIZES WITH
ATHLETES, WE LOVE THE ATHLETES
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE GAMES AND
THEY TRAINED SO HARD TO COMPETE.
OF COURSE, THE IOC THE PROBLEM
IS THEY NEVER SHOULD’VE AWARDED
THE GAMES TO CHINA IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
BUT REWARDING CHINA AFTER ITS
ACTION SURROUNDING THE VIRUS AND
GROSS HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES, IT’S
NOT AN OPTION.
CHINA IS DESPERATELY SEEKING
LEGITIMACY ON THE WORLD STAGE,
AND WE SHOULD NOT GIVE IT TO
THEM VERY OF COURSE CORPORATE
AMERICA IS NO PROBLEM.
THIS IS A LIST OF U.S. COMPANIES
WHO ARE TOP-TIER SPONSORS OF THE
2020 GAMES.
IT’S A BIG ONE.
NOW THE KALE INSTITUTE HAS BEEN
NOW ALSO DISAGREES WITH THE
BOYCOTT AS WELL HE ARGUES THAT A
SOLID BARRIER ALMOST SOLITARY
HOLD UP BY THE U.S. MIGHT MAKE
SOME FEEL RIGHTEOUS, BUT IT
WOULD LIKE BELIEVE YOU
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
A UNITARIAN ACTION WOULD
HIGHLIGHT AMERICA’S ISOLATION.
BEIJING WOULD FEEL EMBOLDENED
MORE CONVINCED THAT NO ONE WAS
COMPARED TO CONFRONT EVEN THEIR
WORST BEHAVIOR.
THE BOYCOTT WOULD SHOW THE WORLD
THAT WE ARE NOT GOING TO TREAT
CHINA AS A NORMAL COUNTRY ANY
LONGER.
PERHAPS WE COULDN’T CONVINCE
SOME OF OUR ALLIES TO JOIN THE
BOYCOTT, BUT THEY’D PROBABLY
SIDE WITH CHINA NO MATTER WHAT
WE DID.
AT LEAST WE WOULDN’T BE SELLING
OUT ARE OWN PRINCIPLES, DOESN’T
THAT COUNT FOR SOMETHING?
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
APPARENTLY NOT MADE REPORTEDLY A
FINAL DECISION ON CHINA.
BUT REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND THE INTERNATIONAL
OLYMPIC COMMITTEE DECIDES TO DO,
WE AS CONSUMERS SHOULD ALL
REFUSE TO WATCH THE GAMES.
THE IOC GETS AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT
OF MONEY FOR THE U.S. TV RIGHTS,
AND WE NEED TO SHOW NBC AND THE
IOC THAT THOSE RIGHTS WILL BE
WORTH IT IF THEY INSIST ON
ACTING AS AS CCP PROMOTER.
HER LEGITIMIZE HER.
ALLOWING CHINA TO BECOME THE
WORLD’S MOST POWERFUL COUNTRY
WAS A CATASTROPHIC FAILURE OF
U.S. POLICYMAKING WITH LAME FORM
EVERYONE FOR GEORGE HWS TO BOOK
JOE BIDEN.
BUT IF WE WANT TO REMAIN
INDEPENDENT OURSELVES, WE
AMERICANS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
GET USED TO THE IDEA OF
SOMETIMES BEING A LONELY BEACON
FOR FREEDOM IN THE WORLD, A
WORLD DOMINATED NOW BY